the name
[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday
November 5th and you just watched
yourself singing in front of a lot of
nerdfighters in Louisville Kentucky the
song you're singing is of course only
available on the paper town secret
collaboration album but I played 20
seconds of it because I liked it so much
it's so fun when I make something up and
then someone else make something up
about the thing I made up so ok
nerdfighters every time Hank plays that
song there's that part where Vaseline
gets drawn out and drawn out and drawn
out and sometimes even though it's no
secret I can't sing on key I like to
sing along to that part and see if I can
outlast Hank on that one note and I've
consistently failed until tonight
then afterwards I read from the part of
Paper Towns that inspired that song and
then went on a long rant about the
importance of imagining the other with
more complexity the problem is finding
Mario or human for all the other
characters book isn't that it's so hard
to figure out what happened or it's so
complicated or anything like that the
problem defining Margo is this when
characters in the book look at Margo
they don't see Martin they don't see
anything essentially true about Marco
what they see is some funhouse mirror
reflection of themselves feel is this
German word means mirror maker like a
guy in a German Village ooh Nathan the
urge was this Eagleman and Mario is this
people--men and Istanbul the nerdfighter
community the community that is built up
around our daily vlogs respond to those
thoughtful and respectful communities
that I've ever been privileged to be a
part of but when it comes to political
discourse the quality of the
conversation plums
Emilio's on on all sides
it just absolutely plummets into
name-calling and oversimplification
you're stupid no you're stupid am i
right no you're right
I really believe that this is a result
not doing a good job imagining what it's
like to be other people the people who
disagree with you are evil they marked
it don't want to destroy America they
are they are not your inner tears nor
fascists they are nominated people good
company motives
who can take multitude just as you think
it's like WH Auden said we must love one
another or die pink watching you be a
rock star is so fun you're made of
Awesome and I'll see you tomorrow
so Catherine i hy i is traveling with us
up there I'm sorry
hello YouTube um XY visit travel
internationally play game of cows which
is where when Catherine Embassy in front
seat you wait to see family to cap and
then if you win as goes you go there
first and I I have been completely
dominated by Catherine us I'm kind of
like counseling team but there was about
30 minutes where they're both asleep I'm
where I totally nominated at Dallas like
I was up like sending to nothing
I don't want to make the monster I mean
very much
house